choisir ses études un moment pas
toujours évident les élèves de première
et terminale accompagnées parfois de
leurs parents sont venus au salon de
l'étudiant
cette année ce n'est pas à versailles
mais au vélodrome qu'il s'est déroulé le
salon avait besoin de s'agrandir
donc on peut accueillir davantage
d'exposants et après il ya tout le côté
pratique aussi qui est qui est un plus
comme comme le parking plus de 5800
visiteurs sont venus découvrir les
possibilités d'orientation
la majorité des secteurs de formation en
enseignement supérieur était représenté
avec une centaine d'exposants
je m'intéresse aux métiers de
l'informatique et tout ça et je n'y voir
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire plus
tard après mon bac e les bts va falloir
mettre sur park au sud
mais d'après ce qu'on m'a dit vous mais
postuler directement dans le dans
l'école qu'on souhaite pour avoir plus
de réponses plus de chance justement
cette école basée à montigny le
bretonneux recherche des alternants pour
la rentrée de septembre
sur leur stand une particularité
l'ouverture d'une licence cyber sécurité
on entend un nouveau destin faut au
niveau de l'actualité des deux grand
besoin donc bah il nous a été demandé
par les entreprises de pouvoir monter
une licence en partant d avec celles ci
on aurait eu écho de tout ce qui est
sécurité base de données traitement de
l'information
parmi les visiteurs des étudiants ont
perdu avec la nouvelle réforme du
baccalauréat c'est de lycéenne en 1ère
sont inquiètes par cette réforme vague
selon elle c'est pas très clair ski
orientation après post bac
on sait par contre c'est pas si on était
au maximum 2
s'informer les élèves ont jusqu'au 12
mars pour faire leur choix d'orientation
sur parcours sup